hey i can't believe you're alive i saw
you die
i mourned you i cried for you come on
what did you expect welcome to the heavy
spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka the guy who
touched himself and created a nexus
event
episode 5 of loki is now here and we're
almost in the end game
the penultimate episode is packed with
big reveals a whole host of variants
easter eggs and some major call backs to
the comics throughout this video we're
going to be breaking it all down but
full spoilers ahead so if you don't want
anything ruined
then i suggest you get pruned smash the
thumbs up button and make sure you
subscribe from not only your account
but also your variants as well without
the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into loki
episode 5.
okay so episode 4 ended with loki and
silvi coming face to face with the
timekeepers after they were captured by
the tva
they managed to escape their confines
and silvi beheaded the central figure
to reveal that it was all a big lie loki
was pruned by ravona rensslayer
and the post-credits scene revealed that
he was actually transported to the trash
timeline of 2020.
now shout out superhero nexus for
pointing out that this scene very much
recaptured the moment in the avengers
when they caught loki loki was left in a
similar position
in which he was on his back and some
characters stood towering over him
the music in this scene even played upon
the avengers theme
and this episode itself is very much
about assembling a number of loki's
this actually pulls directly from the
mighty thor number three in which the
character got together all of his
variants
and amongst these were things like kid
loki who we met in the last episode
the hulking one that was teased at an
episode two and he's standing alongside
the classic viking looking loki that
also appeared in that lineup
there's also an animal version of the
character as well as the classic loki
all of which appear in this episode at
some point
now the episode itself is called journey
into mystery which was initially
published by atlas comics
aka marvel before they became marvel
this series ran from 1952 to 1966
and is very much regarded as a golden
age of door unlucky stories
which does hint towards the plot of this
entry we do take a sort of trip down
memory lane
and see various incarnations of the
character that have appeared throughout
the years
now we pick up in the tva and in a blink
and you'll miss a moment
you can see the words oak island nova
scotia written on the big timeline
monitor
this likely ties back to the oak island
mystery which refers to apparent buried
treasure at the island that holds great
value
no one knows exactly what it is but
people have speculated things like the
ark of the covenant to pirate treasure
and even shakespeare's manuscripts the
camera spins upside down which is quite
disorientating
and we walk from the main monitoring
station to the golden elevator
this is adorned with the tva symbols
that look a lot like a cross between the
infinity symbol
and also an hourglass from here we cut
to the head of the timekeeper
before journeying to the destroyed
timeline now on the old avengers tower
you can see that it reads kang
in the comics this was the company that
stark sold the avengers tower 2
and it was connected to kang the
conqueror who gets several references in
this episode
this opening scene is breathtaking and
it just gives you an idea of the full
scope and scale of the void
o loki says that they have to leave
before they become elias lunch
and fans of the comics will know that
this is a trans temporal cloud
that has the ability to destroy all that
it touches it exists across several
timelines
and can even move through dimensions at
one point it threatened kang's dimension
and potentially in the mcu he may have
captured it and turned it into his guard
dog
from here we occur to the titles and we
join sylvie questioning ren slayer in
the supreme court
where the former escaped at the start of
episode 4. ren slayer seems like she
genuinely wants to learn who's behind
the tva
and also who lied to her she explains
how pruning works
and instead of wiping something from
existence we learn that it's simply sent
to the end of time
here the timekeepers are apparently
building a utopia but
as we see it's absolutely terrible now
the idea of this utopia was of course
brought up by mobius earlier in the
season
and it's clear that the tva very much
view themselves as missionaries almost
carrying out the acts of god
the entire tva just seems like some big
religious system in which its agents
believe they'll be rewarded with
paradise
and hell even the first shot of mobius
was him in a church
so it all ties back to this theme now we
cut back to the void and we see what may
or may not be the mary celeste
the ship was found abandoned with
half-eaten food on the table
but absolutely no sign that there had
been anything untoward
it too is one of the great mysteries and
it's lined up next to ufo
which if you believe stories about the
bermuda triangle are things that
regularly abduct ships
the dialogue the loki's have is
hilarious and amongst the void we see
weird animals that shouldn't exist
and statuesque heads the plan is don't
die
and it's clear the group have been lying
low for as long as they can
in what they describe as a shark tank
now as for kid loki
his introduction in the comics actually
ties heavily in with lady loki
i don't want to go over her origins
again as i've done about three videos on
them so far
but just to give you some context she is
what loki became after the fall of
asgard
the souls of the asgardians ended up
inhabiting the bodies of certain people
and in this new form loki said she was
gonna be a force for good
however that was a lie and she ended up
joining the dark avengers which launched
an attack on the newly formed asgard
loki wanted to rule over it but as
always thor won
and he was killed however we learned
that before this attack
loki had manipulated heller to strike
his name out of the book of hell
which meant he could be reborn instead
of dying hell with one l is of course
the nordic version of it
and loki himself even name-dropped it in
the post-credits scene last week
he was reincarnated into a french boy
named sarura
who was a pickpocket in paris though
found him but he had no memory of who he
was
and tsuru was terrified of this man
chasing after him
saying you're my brother however thought
eventually caught him
and learned from syria that he had
dreams where he carried out horrible
acts loki slowly started to accept that
he
was the villain and thor ended up
restoring his identity
though he did remain in this kid body
from this point out thor acted a lot
like a guardian
and he protected him from odin who was
angry about the asgard invasion
as well as iron man kid loki eventually
came face to face with his older self
and this spirit revealed that his life
and death had all been part of the plan
he knew that he needed contingencies and
put this in place to ensure that he
could be brought back
this pretty much created a loop and the
idea of loops is lays throughout the
show and loki's existence
most notably the version played by
richard e grant now this pulls from oh
loki who we've talked about in several
videos so far
again i don't want to just be repeating
myself but this comic book accurate
costume and the fact that he's an older
variant
lets us know that he's lived through a
lot of things loki in the comics
and very much the mcu has always been
seen as a character that's a stepping
stone which propels others to greatness
this was of course brought up in episode
1 and in agent of asgard an older
version of loki manipulate his younger
self
into almost becoming a bigger and better
version of the character
however the agent of asgard version
ended up leaving and he went off to
become
a positive version of loki now this idea
of loki's improving loki's is very much
late throughout the show
as well as the message that you should
learn to love yourself and there's also
croaky
little little dial so so bad you know
actually that's quite a good one
and boastful loki who carries around a
hammer similar to malnier
i thought last week that he might be
worthy but it looks homemade
and the character's name likely comes
from him being a show off
kid loki in this version killed thor
showing why he's the leader
this is something that every single
version of loki has probably tried to do
at some point
but the fact that he succeeded makes him
a boss we get another shot of the
landscape and can catch yellowjackets
helmet
who you might remember was sucked into a
strange void at the end of ant-man
it's hilarious if he ended up here and
this entire episode just feels like one
big easter egg hunt
we can also catch a missile which may be
the one that hank pym disarmed in the
film alongside the thanos copter
which i'm going to be honest here is my
favorite easter egg in a marvel property
ever
before he was collecting infinity stones
thanos was a menace to the sky
and it's hilarious seeing this goofy
thing amongst the wreckage
now the group hide in a subterranean
base how we catch the rock
aka the frog version of thor trapped
inside a jar
this also has t-365 written on it which
isn't know to throw the mighty 365
which was the first full appearance of
the character we see their little
hideout and this has some cool little
details hidden away in it
now in the corner we can catch a polybus
arcade cabinet
in case you haven't heard of these
there's a weird conspiracy theory
surrounding them
and a lot of questions over whether they
actually existed or not
similar to the db cooper mystery the
show is pulling from real life things in
order to sort of poke fun at some of our
unsolved mysteries and urban legends
according to the internet these game
boxes were capable of mass hypnosis and
mind control
but there's no record of them actually
ever existing
however online people claim to have
played them and according to eyewitness
accounts they were taken away by
mysterious men in black
it's appeared as a joke in a lot of
things including the simpsons and i'm
glad that it's shown up here
as it shows it's all connected
now back at the tva we see sylvie and
ren slayer going through the timeline
with miss minute
i have been saying that the ladder might
be the big bad behind it all
but after her appearance here i feel
like an idiot and i'm taking
the l i did get mentioned in men's
health for that though which is ironic
as i've been sick all week hey having
that no no sure
shout out to the middle man who wrote
that joke on one of my vids and
you congrats to me you're much funnier
than i'll ever be and i'm stealing your
jokes
now they realize that the answers they
seek are past the void itself
and say that they'll find the man behind
the curtain which isn't known to the
wizard of oz
in which the real wizard was simply hid
behind one before sylvie can enact her
plan
the tva security arrive but she
self-prunes instead of handing herself
over
back at the void boastful loki bragg
said he bagged the infinity stones
and defeated iron man and cap which is a
lie
the alligator snarls at him and we
learned that its nexus event was eating
the wrong neighbor's cat
we can also see a box of roxy wine which
likely calls back to the rocks caught
disaster
and also the company roxcon from the
marvel comics
over a burned-out campfire of bowling
pins they share their war stories
and we hear from ol loki exactly what
happened to him
he says that during the events of
infinity war he faked his death instead
of attacking thanos
and it's something that we've long
theorized at the channel he divulges
that he cast himself out
and ended up living as a hermit on a
solitude planet however his love for his
brother is what got him caught
and he talks about how loki's all have
one part to play
this is a call back to agent of asgard
in which the elder vision said that upon
completing his goals that the all mother
revealed to him that it had been a ruse
and that loki could never be a hero
instead he was just a pawn to make
others improve
and this sent him off on a much worse
path loki says that he's going to kill
eliath and that he needs all the help he
can get but they burst out laughing
like everyone does when i say croaky hey
croaky it is a good one
now upon exiting loki comes face to face
with both loki
and several other versions of the
character including my man on the top
right
who looks exactly like the one that we
saw in episode two
now as for what happens in well loki
we've actually done a full plot
breakdown of the entire story
if you're someone who doesn't like
politics and comic books then it might
not be for you
and it took a lot of shots at the 2016
u.s presidential election
i wouldn't really say that it took aside
and it pretty much came to the
conclusion that both sides lied so much
that someone who actually admitted to
lying like loki was a breath of fresh
air
his campaign actually ran on the idea
that he would be constantly lying
but that people tended to vote for the
lies that they wanted to hear
his slogan was even believed with the
word lie highlighted
showing what kind of leader that he
wanted to be after a debate was attacked
by hydra
loki stepped in and saved the day even
though loki was from asgard
he said that because his origins were
based in myths and legends
that his birth story had been retold
several times and thus
this version was born in the usa
can do a really good impression that
cause of my cold now loki ended up doing
all this spin that would come with a
political campaign
and this slowly led his followers and
enemies to cause a civil war in the
country
at his final rally people realized that
he was just spouting catchphrases
and didn't have any real plans loki
ended up withdrawing but the book
finalized with him contacting the
favorite to win
and we learned that him derailing his
own campaign was all part of the plan
though we didn't know who was on the
other end of the line it became clear
that the president would owe loki a big
big favor anyway they all have to work
together
and sylvie wakes up in a nest of
branches that may be what group
protected the guardians with at the end
of their first film
she runs from eliath and during this
gets a vision of a tower at the end of
time
now this looks a lot like colditz which
was a stronghold for the germans during
world war ii
a lot of fascists and dictators have
hung out here and i love that the leader
of this fascist society of the tva
is hanging out here luckily she's saved
by mobius a marvel as always
cheeky cheeky cgi removed her out of
this scene in the trailers
now shout out simone berman on twitter
for pointing out that this could be a
nod to pixar who put a pizza truck in
every one of their films
we also see a pyramid and sphinx which
may be an autorama tut
aka a version of kang that traveled back
in time to ancient egypt in order to be
a pharaoh
maybe a reach probably i reached that
but we'll see we'll see what happens
next week and i'll be like i knew all
along now the loki's are absolutely
furious and we learned that both for
loki betrayed the other ones
which of course is the character's
shining personality trait
both loki's forces betray him and then
the alligator loki bites off but loki's
hand
which leads to all the other loki's
duking it out
gotta hand it to that alligator one he's
a he's a good guy
he hadn't it now oh loki kid loki
loki and alligator loki say see you
later alligator
and they managed to escape it hits them
just how broken they are
and they realize anytime they try and
better themselves they're sent to the
void
it's a moment of self-reflection for
them in which loki fully steps into
being a hero
and mobius has a moment like this too
with sylvie where he comes to the
conclusion that his entire existence has
been based on a lie
sylvie is desperate to find loki and the
latter part of the episode is very much
about loki diverting from the path of
selfishness
in order to do something bigger now as
they circle the landscape we can see a
ship drop in
and can tell from its hull that this is
the uss eldridge
shout out to deidre o'brien on instagram
for pointing this out
and there is a lot that we can take from
it now the uss eldridge is a real life
ship that took part in the philadelphia
experiment
and according to reports from from dude
bro trust me
it was rendered completely invisible now
that might not have happened yet but
my uncle said it did and there's a lot
of myths and rumors surrounding the ship
which have led to some wild theories
being brought up over the years
eyewitnesses have said that the ship was
teleported in new york
some have said it was another dimension
and some have said that it ran into
aliens
there was even claims that the soldiers
aboard it were fused with the hull
and there's just a lot of things
surrounding this ship that makes it a
really cool easter egg
now i absolutely love that the set
designers have really pulled from a
number of things such as this
and db cooper as it just makes the show
feel so much richer
they see mobius and selfie coming over
the horizon and there's lip service
given to cannibalistic marauders
which is something that christopher
columbus claimed to have come across
when shotting america
they have a touching reunion and
hilariously sylvie shuts down the idea
of killing goliath
as she wants to enchant it instead we
see that ren slayer is holding b15
hostage
and that she hasn't pruned her yet
because she wants to know more about
selfie
it's a really good scene in which we can
see how sylvie is now being propped up
as
a hero ren slayer wants to find out
who's behind it all too
and i think at this point it's probably
gonna either be kang or he who remains
those are the only characters
canonically that are really connected to
the tva
and i think we will probably get a tease
to kang before we're properly introduced
to him in ant-man quantomania
loki and sylvie sit outside and he
initially conjures a blanket for himself
which kind of shows how selfish he still
is deep down he is doing a lot of this
for sylvie
but i feel like as a character he's
someone who's still very self-centered
i mean it's taken versions of himself to
realize that and he ends up creating an
even bigger blanket
silvie worries that in the final moments
loki may betray her
and this is of course something that
we've seen the car to do time and time
again
expect the expected when it comes to him
but he says that's not who he is anymore
and promises to not let her down your
bloody better not
now loki and sylvie are clearly flirting
with each other and i know i said last
week that there wouldn't be any romance
between them
but that's because the showrunner
actually didn't interview stipulating
there won't be
you do get a lot of flirty vibes from it
here though so who knows how it's gonna
go
but ryanairy actually came up with a
theory that if they create a child
together
one that was born of variants that it
would completely open up the multiverse
and that's where the show is heading
could well be and as they head out we
can catch the dark aster
which was rounding the accuser's ship in
guardians of the galaxy
silvi wants loki to leave but he decides
to go with her
kid loki gives him a golden blade which
might be another sort of sigurd
a mystical weapon from agent of asgard
mobius returns to the tva and says that
he'll burn it all to the ground
but before he goes loki gives him a big
hug and calls him friend
i'm not crying now just got a really bad
cold now sylvie and loki head out
and shouts to drip underscore corey f on
twitter for pointing out that you can
see the head of the living tribunal
amongst the landscape
this was a cosmic entity that proceeded
over the multiverse
and he was put in charge of safeguarding
it thus someone destroying the tribunal
would allow them to create the tva and i
really like this easter egg amongst the
rubble
oh loki heads out and we can also catch
a heli carrier as well as what i think
might be the skeletons of the whales
that were part of thanos army
we can also catch the lighthouse of
alexandria and shout outs to superhero
nexus for sending that one through
doggy puts himself forward to try and
cause a distraction while sylvie
enchants the beast
however it doesn't really work but when
all hope is lost
o loki manifests a giant version of
asgard to distract a lion
and this makes loki see that they're
stronger than they realize selfie holds
loki's hand
and together the pair enchanted loki has
been unable to do this thus far
but together with their strength
combined they reach inside
sadly o loki dies after sacrificing
himself
which in some ways feels like a full
completion of his character arc
as he of course refused to do it when it
came to thanos
he screams glorious purpose and is
killed
but he buys loki and salvi enough time
to enchant the beast
after parting the clouds much like how
moses parted the red sea
a giant mansion and tower can be seen
adrift in space
now we know that this is indeed a rock
and i'm kind of leaning a lot into the
he who remains theory
due to what we know of the comics in
those he who remains actually create the
timekeepers
at the end of time and he sat there
waiting for the next universal cycle to
begin
i think just due to what we learned in
the episode that he's a likely candidate
however looking at the bigger mcu namely
the casting of jonathan mages as kang
they could be heading into that
direction too there are a lot of easter
eggs and points towards him in this
episode
and yeah it just makes a lot of sense
ren slayer was also his girlfriend in
the comics
so potentially she'll come across him
and then realize
you know what i like being part of the
dba i like being in line with this guy
and that will kind of line up a lot with
the comics now that's what my thoughts
on this series so far
as i'm sure you can guess i'm really
enjoying it and i think the show has
managed to capture the zany idea of the
multiverse really really well
it's giving us a lot of clues for what's
gonna be happening in the mcu going
forward
and i just love how there's the
possibility that anything could really
happen
i think that it's great that a show
called loki has so many different
versions of loki
and at the core it's clear that this
entire thing is about the villain
very much learning to love himself loki
is one of the characters that's gone
through so many different arcs
and he's someone who just can't seem to
push past accepting himself for who he
truly is until it's too late
i love the idea of all these versions
and variants coming together to truly
show what it means to be a loki
and loki is very much using himself to
propel himself forward
into being a hero i think that's what's
at the core of this show
and it's already got me really engaged
i'm just
very very hyped for the finale really
enjoyed it but i know i know from the
comments that there are people out there
who aren't enjoying it as much
but for me i just love when things
examine all iterations of a character
from a top level view
to show us what it truly means to be
them so yeah it's gonna be interesting
to see what happens and i will of course
be back for the finale next week
it's gonna be bittersweet watching it or
wrap up and before i forget
thank you everyone for your support in
getting my videos trending each week on
youtube
i'm really ill at the moment but pushing
through this and i must say that the
support makes it a lot easier
so i love you three thousand obviously
i'd love to hear your thoughts on the
episode so make sure you comment below
and let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
show on the 30th of july
in which we randomly pick three comments
to win an mcu boxer of your choice
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our videos
linked on screen right now
which will be perfect the perfect thing
to follow up this i swear
now without the way thank you missing
through the video i've been paul i'll
see you next time
take care peace